الان الى المشهد الاوكراني حيث قال
المتحدث باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه
اندريوس ان فيلقين يعرفان باسمي فيلق حريه
روسيا وفيلق المتطوعين الروسي ينفذان
عمليه داخل الروسيه لانشاء ما سماه منطقه
امنيه لحمايه المدنيين الاوكرانيين في
المقابل اعلن حاكم مقاطعه
اشخاص اصيبوا جراء هجوم نفذته مجموعه
اوكرانيه على المقاطعه الحدوديه كما اعلن
حاكم ايضا تفعيل ما سماه النظام القانونيه
لعمليه مكافحه الارهاب في المقاطعه
معنى الالم من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز
دويري يعني الحديث عن هذه الفيال
الاوكرانيه التي
صرح عنها او اتحدث عنها المخابرات
الاوكرانيه من هي هذه الفيالق وما مهمتها
برايك وهل تعبر عن استراتيجيه اوكرانيه
جديده
لا هو منذ عده اشهر بدا الحديث عن جماعات
مناويه لنظام الكرملين وهي جماعات تعمل
داخل الاراضي الروسيه وهي جذورها روسيه
لان اوكرانيا تنمى بنفسها عن اي عمل يتم
داخل الجغرافيا الروسيه باستثناء مهاجمه
بعض القواعد العسكريه بالطائرات المسيره
هي تسرع عن اي هجمات على شبه جزيره القلم
او داخل دومباس بصوره عامه وبالتالي فرق
حريه روسيا الذي اعلن عنه اليوم لا يزال
الاسم تشوب الكثير من الضبابيه لكن
الساعات القادمه ستكشف على انها
جماعات قد يكون لها ارتباط مع اوكرانيا
ولكنها
تعكس كما تقول لفظ الشارع الروسي وانا
تعارض سياسه الحرب على اوكرانيا وتعرض
توجهات الكرملين
طيب ما هي الدلاله التي تحملها استهداف
هذه المقاطعه الحدوديه في بيل غرود الان
وما المتوقع
بعد ذلك
يعني لماذا بالقرود بالقرود تتميز بالعديد
من الميزات وقد تم وصفه بانها القاعده
الاستراتيجيه الاداريه المثلى
لتدريب القوات الروسيه
ولانطلاق القوات الروسيه ولتعزيز منظومه
الامداد يضاف الى ذلك انها اولا قريبه
المسافه ما بين مدينه
وخاركيف 71 كيلو متر
بقياسا مع العمق الروسي هي تعتبر بلده
حدوديه يضاف الى ذلك بها شبكه مواصلات
وبها طريق سريع يربط مع شبه جزيره القرم
وبها شبكه سكه حديد منها ما يربط مع ميناء
سيفل في شبه جزيره القرم فيها اربعه انهار
رئيسيه وبالتالي تعتبر منطقه مثاليه
للاستهداف
اي استئتاف لها قد يؤتي اكله اذا ما كان
ناجحا ولكن بالمقابل حتى لو كانت اوكرانيا
او جماعات محسوبه على اوكرانيا هي من نفذت
اوكرانيا لن تعترف بذلك ولن تصرح بذلك
لانها تتحدث دائما عن تحرير اراضيها دون
الدخول امام مواءمه مع لا تطلعات الغربيه
الى داخل الجغرافيا تفعيل ما سمي بالنظام
القانوني لعمليه مكافحه الارهاب في تلك
المقاطعه والتي قلت بانها منطقه مثاليه
للاستهداف ما المقصود به
يعني هنا تفعيل حاله الطوارئ الان لاحظي
عمليات للتفتيش عمليات مراقبه الاتصالات
عمليات
ما يطلق عليها مكافحه الارهاب اذا هي فرض
قوانين انجاز التعبير كانها تفرض قوانين
طوارئ وتضع هذه المنطقه احد ما يسمى مجازا
بقوانين الحرب اي كبت الحريات تحديد
الحركه المداهمات
والاعتقال قبل التحقق من البراعه اذا
مجموعه من الاجراءات الغايه منها وهذه
تطبق في معظم الدول في حال حدوث اي حدث من
ذلك يتم تضييق الحريات وتحديد الحركه
والمداهمات والاعتقالات من اجل احتواء
الحدث
الى اي مدى يعني تشكيل او انشاء منطقه
امنيه لحمايه المدنيين
الاوكرانيين والتي تسعى تلك الفيالق
لتنفيذها في منطقه ممكن ان تشكل يعني
كما نقول يعني دفاعا لهؤلاء المدنيين
يعني اولا انت تتحدثي عن مدنيا اوكرانيين
الان المدنيين الاوكرانيين اما ان يكونوا
داخل اوكرانيا او ان يكونوا موجودين
يعملوا في في روسيا او من حمله مزدوجي
الجنسيه واذا هذه الثلاثه عطر التي يمكن
الحديث عنها اذا كانوا اوكرانيين موجودين
على الاراضي الروسيه فهناك مئات الالاف من
الاوكرانيين الموجودين ومن المؤكد انهم
تحت نظر المراقبه والمتابعه للوكالات
الامنيه الروسيه لانهم يخشوا من ايه
عمليات اما ان ينشا كنتونات حمايه
للاوكرانية داخل روسيا لا اعتقد ان هذا
الامر مبالغ فيه لماذا لانه تم ترحيل مئات
الالاف من شرق اوكرانيا الى روسيا اشكرك
لواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان